pop
tous
e
[Musique]
ah ah
m
ah ouais
[Applaudissements]
enfin
[Musique]
d
maman la bougie qui avait presque fini
on dirait qu'elle n'en mange moi je pose
pour le ppc dans ma chambre disponible
elle se paye pendant les heurts c'était
choquant il ya htc sida comme serge
péter mais elle finira par me coucher je
tremble déjà
quand tu fais je t'aime je te tiendrait
la figure devant une glace bay figurer
joli teint promesse de [ __ ] faut
maintenant pas maintenant ce soir chez
ge pleine lune tu sais bien que mon
ennemi va penser je dois écrire au garde
à vous arrêter mais l'ennemi n'est pas
sa mère dont que le patron du paléo est
rentré ses tables il adaptera dit que
vous bariz deviendraient des cours
d'appui
si vous ne voyez pas une promenade tous
les soirs où c'est bien alors que vous
êtes déjà à trouver le poteau de
panneaux et vote n'est pas ce que vous
payez les voies mains qui tremblent
comme des méduses sur la mersey oui bah
tout comme aimer mais ne tremblait pas
sur mes pinceaux voilà ce qui attend un
peu d'avoir 80 d'entre eux est pêché
d'ailleurs on verra je ne tremble pas
oui bon ça va je vais jusqu'à la ville
voir mes raisins je reviens à l'hepia
bien mais parfois tu un peu oui ces
figures et joli teint ouais tu sais ce
que je te ferai j'ai dû regarder un
garçon deux fois avant que ta chère soit
marié ou ip t elle c'est ouais bon les
balaurs tâche de ne pas l'oublier mais
morel je vous le promets à l'atp en
scène
cette petite facture comme l'eau du ciel
c'est vous pleuriez des idées avec mon
fils est malade
non mais bon s'il se plaisait pas c'est
un garçon pour qui n'attendent que le
diable et femmes iowa bien et moi il est
juste ce garçon qui attend ton doigt
georges abbou j'espère bien je ne
connais pas et n'en contrôle si qu'ils
imaginent ans la maman simone manque
beaucoup à tout de suite aller briller
un peuple et voilà je nettoie et la
cuisine aux nuits maman gina n'oublie
pas de prendre tes gouttes à l'égard des
prières qui a bien des choses à demander
au bon dieu m'a déjà tellement donné il
a lui même qui partent à donner accès
aux salles dont celle donnée qu'à moi il
ya une abrogation et honnête le ppe a
voté 5 milliards pour finir de payer sa
mule
il fait pas l'élément de leur hymne
épouse sally fera deux minutes c'est des
choses comme ça que tu te prépares à lui
dire demain matin n'ai pas peur j'aurai
tout ami pour les vidéos pour filles on
croit que ça fait plaisir d'être méchant
ni dans nos verres du sahara non tenues
tu as bien portant sur les affaires peut
se mettre à plusieurs pour consoler des
casseurs tu es gentil avec elle est
gentil avec toi je ne demande pas tant
elle fait tout ce que tu veux tu n'es
pas promener les pieds le feu mais il ya
six voitures brûlées le champ propre à
toute seule elle est partie coucher au
braille et enfin il se jettera vont
faire pour toi qu'est ce qu'elle attend
qu'est ce que tu attends pour aller
dormir
d'abord dans fano il n'y a pas ces
points d'écouté et pulsion procès lapin
si tu as entendu le pp ils se cassaient
pleine lune ce soit il faut le laisser
gaieté et lâcher son coup de fusil sur
la terre bio ni un homme qui repose
depuis un an au cimetière pour pépé si
saleh qui tient sur un homme mort et
enterré depuis longtemps et c'est toi
qui peut dresser belge ou de carriole
qui nous donne le pain bonsoir vraiment
china quand tu dors ça t'arrive de rêver
pourquoi parce que chez vous en calabre
on dit que ce que dieu aime il est fait
rêver en couleurs les autres et même en
noir et blanc
alors tu rêves comment que jamais dit
que je rêvais tu ne tourne pas la clé
c'est le cas nous la tournée piano ce
qu'elles sont et resteront bonnes nuits
du même nom du accordé à manque au
bain-marie fabrizio la gloire de votre
ciel sommes tamadone intercéder pour lui
et toi moko enfin lucho maintenant que
tu sais tout depuis 22 ans quand je
t'avoue chaque soir pardonne à ta pauvre
teresa maintenant que tu tombé au champ
d'honneur
j'en faisais attention celui de
déshonneur c'était si loin ce n'était
qu'un américain est ce que ça coûte tuer
mais notre pauvre gina tage 2 mais ma
pauvre pia puisque personne n'en sait
rien c'est à toi qu'elle fait honneur 1
allée à demain soir et à tous les soirs
jusqu'à mon dernier souffle sur cette
dure terre romaine
bonsoir telle est la promesse je disais
ma prière du soir avant pauvre fabrizi
on sait bien ma fille lui avoir à
continuer longtemps à perdre et je ne
sais pas encore s'il m'a pardonné aux le
temps ne dure aux vivants je vous
apportera bâton c'est pareil tout fait
viande font des petits lapins
non non non non teresa la nouvelle que
j'apporte le mérite porte un petit verre
d'euros cholet fait nouvelle
il s'agit de nos mesures de nos mesures
portent des noms rival non il est venu
me voir avant le dîner il avait le
chapeau les souliers la valise
il a vendu sa mule il rend sa parole à
jean à ça veut dire pas la sienne mon
dieu c'est une tragédie c'est ce que
sous nos yeux ne pas un fantôme il n'est
pas aussi dire nuit avant de m'asseoir
le pépé lui a ravi des les deux canons
de son fils d'ali
c'est bien ce qu'il a pensé aussi je
vous ai dit qu'il avait des souliers
autour du cou le chapeau la valise il
descendait sur palerme avec un billet
d'avion pour milan s'entame hadorn pour
une fois que nous entamions dieu ne vous
abandonne pas un autre viendra dans la
cause est en mal d'imagination je
n'aurais pas cru parce qu'être oled pour
qu'on puisse se croit été donnée ça me
lire il n'avait qu'à m'en parler j'en
aurais vu autant de la pole c'est bien
ce que je me suis permis de lui faire
comprendre
non non la laideur ils étaient prêts à
s'y habituer
il n'était pas si vous lui même arrêté à
nantes
déjà mais qu un prêté pour un rendu non
non c'est plutôt qu'elle lui faisait
peur un garçon de gaffard au père du
nord à gaza moi je lui en ai fait honte
mais il m'a répondu
j'interprète bien sûr la peur a ses
raisons que la raison ne connaît pas la
magie n'allait pas vraiment méchant
peut-être un peu jalouse ou encore sur
toute sa soeur et tout ça tout ça parce
que tu n'as pas saisit vous oubliez
teresa nom n'a pas été juste il me
donnait filles dans le devoir et la
fidélité szerzyna et après une fille de
la luxure et le péché et sépia
j'appelle ça j'appelle ça une injustice
à tripoli non je vous dispense de croire
en dieu si c'est pour l'injurier merci
pour les lapins et bonne nuit
[Applaudissements]
dis-moi pécheresse qui dans cette maison
c'est qu'il ya 22 ans
tu t'es fait faire un enfant par un
américain trois jours après que son
infortuné fabrizio et rejoint son unité
pour sauter sur une mine
personne de pavano personnes si vous
n'avez pas violé le secret d'un complice
j'aimerais faire métrage nous est envoyé
par la figure personnes tuées sur nepean
et jean alesi mais ce vieux pays
s'il savait que j'ai trempé son fils l'a
fait il aurait déjà crucifié sur la
porte de la grange et gina l'oreille en
chantant et ma pauvre à pia qu'est ce
que ça aurait jeté dans le puits rien
n'est plus sûr et ben continue à
demander ton pardon at on des fins evian
fait je ne sais pas s'il t'a pardonner
mais tu as sûrement légué sa chance de
cocu et ça c'est plus tôt possible
avant de venir de confesser samedi tu te
s'amendera la bourre jusqu'à la grotte
pour les belles choses que tu m'as dit
et me manque pas je te ferai demain
soufflé au nez à travers le grillage en
manque d'écouté
bonsoir on prend pas l'eau bonsoir de
l'intéressé tu es lèvres aussi des
lapins à main non non je n'élève pas des
lapins non j'instruis des cabris jusqu'à
ce que les corps de leurs pouces et
j'essaie aussi le sauver cette famille
des tâches ou et de la mendicité en
tenant les comptes et les déclarations
fiscales de dosnon de ces mots à votre
disposition quand il vous plaira pas
dans mes bras mon fils je paie au
vatican qui n'a parlé dans l'e-mail il
chasse le temps et qu'on nous présente
du temps l'aimable fiancée et marion
dans deux semaines jour pour jour si
tout mon école fermée elle sera ici avec
sa maman et le mariage ce sera pour
quand eh bien le lendemain de son
arrivée si vous le dernier donc fano et
la publication des bans vie jours avant
à l'église qu'est ce que tu en fait vous
vous en dispense une fois sur deux ça
vous fera une paire de lapins de plus
dans votre clavier je vous le promets
oui bon bah ça va ça va on leur parle à
propos de mariage dites moi si vous
n'avez jamais vu de mariée aussi jolie
elle fait la grimace parce qu'elles
effacent au soleil oui mais la robe est
mignonne c'est elle qui l'a fait oui non
je ne vous la montre pas de l'intérêt à
vous l'avez vu et son prénom c'est
rosalia rosalia falcon un rosalia est
une grande synthe pour ton mariage j'ai
traînerait la chasuble rose et argent
dont les dames théâtre ils m'ont fait
cadeau aux mairies
bonsoir teresa bonsoir l'instituteur ne
soit pas bon
j'oubliais fois félicité la domus dominé
amer à l'eau je n'arrive pas trop tard
non non le préfet est allé faire son
tour jusqu'aux vignes avec pia quand il
reviendra je n'ai papiers importants à
lui faire signer dans la serviette
j'ai aussi la fausse barbe et le vieux
chapeau pensez bien qu'il n'a pas oublié
que nous étions à la pointe de la pleine
lune il ya passé toute la journée
pauvre pp 6 avec liqya sur un mort et
enterré depuis longtemps il n'y a pas de
danger de l'intérêt à tout le pays et
complice quand je passe avec le vieux
scooter
tout ça c'est très joli mais si vous
attrapez un soir une belle volée de
chevrotine dans la figure ou dans les
rames votre rosalia eh ben elle sera
peuvent avant d'être votre femme
il n'y a pas de danger d'un intéressant
ça fait pas sur le fusil du pp a fait
coups de feu avec carrie bradshaw il ne
tire pas plus loin qu'un lance pierre
allons ne vous tourmentez pas de
l'intéressé regardez plutôt s'il ne
revient pas alors non bon la fausse
barbe le vieux chapeau au papier votre
réclamation pour votre arriérés de
pension de veuve de guerre
la déclaration néant du pp sur ses
bénéfices agricoles et la demande de
votre fille gina pour sa nouvelle carte
d'identité à son épouse alors tout à
signer où j'ai mis une croix
je viendrai reprendre ça demain matin
les bons soirs de l'intéressant des
mario vous pouvez reprendre cette loi et
la déchirer gina ne se marre web plus
oh non c'est pas vrai lamarre a pris sa
parole il est déjà loin
oh non non non c'est pas vrai elle est
aussi vrai que je suis là on la crapule
merci mario de compatir donc moi qui
voyait si bien les noces de votre jean
un essai de marc aux alliages un jour le
pp est au courant car ça n'en prend pas
même gina c'est le parent qui vient de
rapporter la nouvelle je la garde pour
moi jusqu'à demain matin
une mauvaise nouvelle fais moi mal le
matin ah oui peut-être
oui oui peut-être que moi aussi demain
matin ça ira mieux à l'eau du courage de
l'intéressé il en viendra un autre je
vous le promets je vais me creuser la
tête épluché les listes aux municipales
il doit bien rester encore un ou deux
garçons si vous pouviez doubler la note
fait déjà doublé mais gouttes
ouais c'est toujours ça
mais pas plus sympa p 10 si c'était pas
un péché c'est tout le flacon que j'ai à
malleray oui allez bon soir d'un teresa
demain est un autre jour
gabon fait il ya ça va gonfler la digue
des prix des places pour fauteuils et
tire le volet avec la fente pour laisser
passer mon fusil les dépêche toi ce soir
il ya une lune comme un soleil avant
l'heure la bête sur un crevé et l'oncle
luigi salvan g non je sois ce soir je ne
suis pas sûre ce soir je le sais moi
c'est tout et après vous n'aurez pas
honte d'avoir tué un homme sans
confession la moitié du plaisir d'un
panneau est passé prend d'écouter les
épluchures procès d'un maillot à porter
à papier cas vous devrez signer non pas
d'abord lieu maintenant je me concentre
là qu'on me foute la paix l'épia
allument des bougies et celle de ta mère
toi et toi intérêts ça souffle la lampe
oui y'a pas louise et quand je fais
quelque chose serait le tout de suite
quoi elle a pu monter vous coucher que
vous puissiez juré devant dieu et au
tribunal que vous n'avez rien vu alors y
est avec poupée ou non mais ce soir dieu
dieu c'est dieu chez moi alors
avant 2006 péter wedde fillette en
jetons échelle parce que les carabinieri
l'hta drop est arrivé quand le temps
bionique commencera à gueuler en
appelant ses marges
on craque et une pour les joints dans ce
chien et j'ai encore acté je le rachat
annoncé en avril doit pas trop vite eu à
son scooter
tu atteins je le rate encore une fois
bon dieu que je rate encore une fois je
me tranche le poignet émotions font rien
du tout pour thomas mann tremblements et
en moyenne chez mon pote je suis poli
c'est vous donne ses mots qui avait tiré
sur son pouvoir quand les tombes johnny
qui traversait la place sur son scooter
ça ne te regarde et pop il ya des
chanteurs regarde pas je suis là loin
donne seulement ça il faut saluer les
affaires de famille impie sur la loi du
tout je ne peux dire est ce que moi si
tu m'envoies au tribunal moi je dirais
que je dirais que je nettoyais mont fuji
et que tu étais souvent en retard on
doit l'assumer tout le tollé tout le
village viendra témoigner jusqu'aux
petits enfants et c'est encore toi qu'on
enverra en prison pour avoir jeté la
honte sur mes cheveux blancs je suis
fatigué pèse plus que ça manque pas
seulement si vous nettoyez votre fusil
une fois de trop et qu'on retrouve le
poste tombe bien venir est mort devant
chez vous avec son poids de chevrotine
dans le corps même si tous friot l'eau
vient témoigner qu'il est bien vivant
ce sera mauvais pour vous c'est encore
toi qu'on enverra en prison portait
parfaitement parce que tout frais yolo
viendra témoigner pour dire pour qui un
culte était ivre mort l on paie ma
grappin que tu t'es jeté sur mon fusil
et que tu as toi descendu le temps que
you need de son scooter et pourquoi
j'aurais fait ça peut-être pour pour me
remercier de magra et non merci dans le
seul mot pas quand je rentre chez moi la
première chose que ma femme me demande
de lui souffler dans le nez mais si vous
voulez me faire un vrai plaisir
j'ai bien des je t'aime comme un fils
voiture anti aurore douce pour un fils
un fils qui serait pas alors approché la
langue de votre peinture s'il vous plaît
tu veux la garder
ou peut-être pas si bête tu connais
karajan moyens lui aurait glissé
santamato et si vous étiez un grand
peintre sans savoir
c'est pour un brigadier kabylie me le
prendrais tu allais la bonne huile en
panne et va souffler dans l'état femme
cissé s'assemble
signature bolino si je vous avais fait
huit enfants en huit ans vous penseriez
comme elle ce qui est du jeu m'avait
fait huit enfants les camps
non mais ça va pas non oui c'est une
manif les filles au pôle muséal sfr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la fia mon amour relève qu'à barda perd
ses poils il faut pas trop lui en
demander un set semble que je peux de
poupée et puis ne soit pas bête la
charge de plomb est passé au dessus du
clocher un jeune tueur a fait l'idiot
une fatwa est basse et surtout qu'un
jour sa vieille pétoire lui éclatera
dans la figure mais ne t'inquiètes pas
j'ai trouvé la solution
enlevez la moitié de la poudre de ses
cartouches
la prochaine fois quand tu l'emmènera
promener je montrerai comment faire à ta
maman tu m'aimes un peu je crois oui
plus que rosalia la perle de branne 10
il ne manque pas de rosalia ma plus
belle boxe et si elle savait le métier
que je fais faire ici enfin demain je
lui écrirai pour qu'elle m'envoie de
nouvelles photos à tous peut faire quand
elles arriveront gino sera déjà marié tu
auras tout avoué et vie joue plus tard
nous sont mariés à notre tour et
justement non mon amour comme en non
quelqu'un dans triolo appris que rosalie
a été ta soeur j'ai une mauvaise
nouvelle le malheur ne vient pas de ma
soeur mais de la vienne jean a encore
non il va lui falloir jouer la comédie
est encore un petit moment
je le sais là depuis tout à l'heure
pendant que tu promener le pp ce
[ __ ] deniau a fait reprendre sa
parole pardonne fofana et il a décampé
pour milan entre parenthèses avec les
15000 lire que je lui avais donné pour
acheter son complexe
mario ce n'est pas que si et si entre
nous je crois que j'aurais fait la même
chose mais ne t'inquiète pas je vais en
trouver un autre
et celui-là trois mois je lui
rembourserait le costume je lui avant
serait pas mais un mois un mois et demi
au plus allons bien nous n'avons pas
vendu la tente trop pénible tamada
qu'est ce que tu as assure jean actu
plaise ou non c'est pas un sou de finale
tu m'as fait un bébé mario
miséricorde mais à quoi il pense que le
bon dieu là haut
c'est pas le moment de blasphème et tu
sais j'ai mon amour tu es sûre non oui
j'en suis sûr mille fois et le désastre
c'est pour quand on veut que je sache je
crois oui la nuit où tu m'as donné la
leçon sur les planètes
je ne comprenais pas ce vide tu m'as
fait pleurer puis après ben tu n'as
consoler ça remonte loin ça au moins
deux mois on a plutôt 3 ou mario mais
qu'est ce qu'on va faire mais qu'est ce
qu'on va devenir
non non ne t'inquiète pas demain matin
je parlerai au pp mais tu es fou voilà
trois siècles que la leur déficit
paulino veut coller les se marient avant
la cadette
oui faire autrement c'est bien que la
crucifier l'aîné sang a coulé pour moi
parce que c'était aussi avoué que la
cadette avait fait des siennes
il y a de la honte pour tout ce mario tu
peux pas faire ça mais si je le fais
rose mais si tu le fais mais aussi sûr
que je t'aime le pp te lâchera les bus
canon de son fusil dans la poitrine et
moi ils m'enverraient faire la bonne
dans une auberge de palerme
en attendant connaître me tromper bien
l'assistance et puis aussi votre maman
ok tu avais dit bon mario
on ne pleure pas fiable commenté que je
pense si tu pleures tu sais combien de
temps avant nous avant que ça se voit
c'est pas deux mois deux mois
si dieu est bon quelques phases de lune
avec 16 des voix
ce n'est qu'un fiancée à trouver pour
gina a décidé le 5 le quatrième une fois
de plus finale en voudra pas où c'est
lui qui se sont à la dernière minute
y'a pas avec mon argent cette fois point
il me reste deux cents livres pour finir
le mois yann moix la pièce d'or de ma
première communion
alors alors l'âme c'est toi oui tu
m'apprends rien j'ai aussi appris via
écoute moi demain matin tu ramassera
toutes les affaires que tu pourras moi
je ne descendra pas les ans je prendrais
tout ce que j'ai ma montre mes livres la
mappemonde de l'école et demain soir
quand ils dormiront de nous sauverons
mais je sais pas moi dans le nord en
piémont pour vivre mario pour vivo
toiture a perdu ta paye des instituteurs
mais je t'ai bras ce qu'ils savent faire
tes bras afin de me serrer quand une en
brasse puis même en piémont tu as lu les
journaux
ils sont dix à s'entretuer pour une
heure de travail eh bien nous passerons
en france j'enseignerai l'italien qui
veut à bord dont l'italien sauf en
italie dans toutes les soirées fléchir
moi quand j'ai un problème je me demande
ce qu'aurait fait garibaldi
ça je peux te jurer qu'il ne m'aurait
pas fait un enfant oh allez souffler la
bougie ça m'empêche de réfléchir et puis
bien allongé près de moi non je ne suis
plus à craindre bien j'ai trouvé
garibaldi n'ont donc falot new mario mal
si tous fans ont marqué ce traitement
ça ne serait pas le bébé et tout sera
aussi terrible qui n'a pu regarder en
face alors ça sera au moins une
consolation
écoute moi bien tient demain je dirai
tout de toi et de moi adoptant fan ou
non en confession rassure-toi saluera le
bec
alors il faut que le pad c'est ça il
faut que le pad phase comprendra gina
qu'elle ne se mariera jamais qui lui
explique bien que le mieux pour elle
pour ne pas être la risée public c'est
de bien vite prendre les devants mais
quelle devant d'épouser le plus beau de
tous notre seigneur jésus
ce fair nonnes oui mais quand le padre
l'ancien persuaderait le pape de mettre
un fauve est encore et puis quand je lui
aurais dit que nous attendons un petit
messi il ne pensera plus qu'à ça ces
biens durables me dis mais qu'est ce que
tu crois qu'un curé cécilien entend en
confession des vols de pizzas du travail
le jour du seigneur
mais qu'est ce qui va passer de toi que
je suis un menteur d'élite qui lui
facilitera la besogne et deux mois eh
ben c'est à toi qui le dira mais même si
jean a dit oui à donf enfin oui combien
de moins avant la prise de voile
combien de mois avant m'a dit qu'elle
était latine mais ça n'empêche pas
tondre cantal aude annoncé dimanche que
jean hachey paulino appelé
irrévocablement par le seigneur entre au
couvent dt ha tinh lundi je demande tama
la famille me saute au cou dimanche en
huit
la noce joie dans le ciel et sur la
terre si seulement je pouvais tu crois
rappelle toi quand j'étais après que les
baleines n'était pas du poisson tu n'as
pas voulu croire non plus tu mens comme
tu respires c'est surtout qu'un mensonge
ne vient jamais seul et quand tu dis tu
mal je mens
ce n'est que le millième de la vérité je
voudrais tout de même bien être à demain
alors souffler la bougie ça viendra plus
vite
[Applaudissements]
oh
je n'en pouvais plus d'attendre mois
fallait bien que je termine ma classe et
le petit maglio saigner du nez il a
fallu que je ne réponds pas je sais par
an tu as parlé au peintre oh là là oui
qu'est ce qu'il a dit il a acheté sa
calotte par terre et de la piétiner
mais c'est tout non je vais pas faire la
conversation par la fenêtre ils ne sont
pas revenus
enfin le gain de 6 heures seulement et
gina à la remise ne traîne déjà mais les
pommes de terre
ils ont signé les papiers je leur ai
laissé hier soir alors je viens pour les
chercher donc faut pas nous à venir te
parler seulement il ne t'apporte pas des
fleurs s'il ne trouve pas seul il veut
que tu passe demain matin au presbytère
sinon il va essayer north ascension il
n'a rien promis
il était furieux tu le connais il a dit
que nous envoyons daniel dans la course
aux lions
vade retro satanas est vain d'attendre
dans la sacristie j'ai des devoirs à
corriger mobile et tend à oublier
d'autres
alors si vrai tu m'as fait de belles
confections toi en tout cas je n'ai pas
communier où est ta soeur pécheresse à
la remise tram à menton pp à palerme
ils vont revenir dans la gare de six
heures est ce que tu te rends compte que
si tu mourrais maintenant c'est en enfer
que tu irais le faire ton bébé qui le
baptise ray le diable avec du soufre et
de l'eau bouillante et que tu es couché
avec instituteur cet arrière qui la
voulait peut-être tu es bien sûr que
personne ne sait rien non seulement
mario mon ange gardien
abbey s'est pas fatigué
et est assez naturel c'est que son audio
à décamper avec les 2000 lire que je lui
avais prêté pour la frime ce dimanche
oui maman le lui a dit ce matin là
pleurer tina ne pleure jamais dont
fofana tu n'aimes pas tu as her samarie
aux trois skis tahri allez va la
chercher dix pages vous allez réussir
pas qu'est ce que j'en sais dieu est
partout mais pas à la fois mais ce
serait épouvantable si vous manquez ça
je sais allez va la chercher
c'est pas la peine de me rendre d'ici là
dans son salon de toi je sais pas
bon bah tu sois disant fusil alors
fermeture dans le four s'il est allumée
au
tu n'as tu n'as jeu je ne te dérange pas
moins genre à celle issue des pommes de
terre
as tu t y es tu as raison tu as raison
elles ont des yeux et ne voit pas vous
êtes déranger pour me faire rire
enfin je veux dire pour me consoler
l'évangile dit heureux ceux qui pleurent
parce qu ils seront consolés et moi
j'ajouterais heureux ceux qui console
parce qu'ils seront pleurés je
m'appelais en attend 500 personnes
voulaient surtout tu ne pleure pas
facilement
pensez donc ça pourrait me l'hedim et il
n'y a pas que la beauté périssables ma
fille
il y à la beauté de larmes que dieu ne
refusa personnes ont-ils la dispute pas
non plus pendant trente siècles on ne
s'est pas disputé non plus pétrole
j'ai fait j'ai fait un rêve magnifique
set mais ne vit pas on est elle apparue
et ben justement si non mais attention
attention je ne dis pas que c'est dieu
qui me l'a envoyé serait venu enfin une
jusqu'à preuve du contraire
je je je te voyais dans le grand jardin
de nos saintes dame t at il dû porter
leurs plus belles robes de fine laine
blanche leurs coiffes et les leurs longs
rosaire noir pendait à ta ceinture des
mains et des cachets dans des manches
je ne voyais que ton visage tout baigné
de paix des yeux me souriait tout
embellie par une suave sérénité et
jamais été dans le jardin des dames
théâtre mais je ne me suis jamais dit
qu'ils aient fait justement tout surpris
pour ne pas dire émerveillé je te
demandais ce que tu faisais là et tu me
répondait avec une infinie douceur
si si mon père je respire les fleurs
j'écoute les oiseaux je chante avec la
gloire de jésus mon fiancé qui jamais ne
trahi ni n'abandonne et qui me chérira
éternellement
j'en avais assez de ce misérable village
de frioul où les enfants sont méchants
les hommes grossiers les fameux
malveillantes ou nous nous et rire de
moi parce que mon visage était était
différent par sa gravité sa mélancolie
et où des rustres par quatre fois
m'avait abusé de promesses mensongères
et c'est tu sais tu comment tu terminais
s'envoyer prendrai mes sandales est
dense et la tarentelle ça j'aurais
trouvé ça tout à fait naturel et ben non
pas du tout non tu me disais dans une
femme fano lagrasse m'a trouvé et j'ai
trouvé ma voie
passez votre chemin
faut vous réveiller d'enfants panneaux
mais pas si votre schéma tout de même
j'ai trois sacs de pommes de terre radis
germées et recouvrir amandine it up je
sais je sais maintenant d'où m'est venue
ce rêve d'abord de la frange méchanceté
qui t'a frappé ce matin mais aussi parce
qu'hier c'était mon jour de visite au
couvent de monter gardot et que la
supérieur m'a dit que bien de ses filles
partaient pour leur mission et que ces
jours ci la communauté se ferait une
joie d'accueillir les armes qu'ils
solliciteraient leur noviciat au fond la
bonne mère n'est pas si accueillante
d'habitude la règle dt ha tinh et si
douce que les demandes ne manquent pas
d'autant plus que l'ordre n'exige pas la
donne s'ils arrêtent me vient je
viendrai vie vous le racontez vos
enfants mon enfance est une grande
publicité pour une famille que d'avoir
parmi les siens une religieuse qui dédie
ses jours et ses nuits alors gagné le
ciel au lieu de finir avant la hache
dans des travaux morose et insipide sans
cet été at in je parlais mais c'est bon
ils tapent en panneaux le seigneur dit
quelque part qui veut me suis doit fuir
père et mère et ses sociétés comme de sa
première pizza à pompons propre pensée
terme petit malheureuse à nous mêmes qui
abandonne les siens pour gagner le sial
ne l'airé rose pas moins de sa gloire
je crois que ce n'est rien que d'avoir
dans une famille une sainte
à la rigueur une bienheureuse à priolo
on y préfère une seconde gratuite
mon enfant mon enfant pour mettre un peu
de baume sur ton coeur à vif vient ce
soir à l'église prier devant la relique
de notre grande si gilliot peut-être que
son doigt miraculeux et indiquera le bon
chemin
le miraculé de santis ils y ont tous fui
yolo c est vous le premier que des
soldats américains l'ont super ya 25 ans
et que ton galbani votre prédécesseur la
remplacer par le doigt d'un homme qu'on
a retrouvé griller dans les décombres du
moulin pantois et peut-être que tout
friot le site china et moi le premier
mais tous friot l'eau c'est moi le
premier que ce droit est celui de
quelqu'un qui a souffert le martyre et
que dieu n'a pas inspiré en vain le
choix du vénérable donc album
à preuve que ce droit fait reculer la
grêle est tombée la plus quand c'était
folie de l'espèce si je ne viens pas je
vous enverrai qu'à un enjeu vos trois ça
[Musique]
promet mais elle mes nerfs
j'ai dit entendu j'étais resté caché
derrière la pergola mes enfants mois moi
j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu
c'est vrai merci par enfin j j'ai
peut-être se met le bon grain
si au moins vous n'aviez pas ce mélo il
est déjà en herbe
oh oui alors il n'y a plus qu'une chose
après trois lacs est persuadé donnant
seulement de marié pierre davant sa
soeur mais ni vous ni le pape ni le bon
dieu la tourelle temps ce ça peut vous
être en en prime où il n'y a plus de roi
en france
et secundo il ya la loi des chip haut
niveau consacrée par les larmes et le
sang
mais enfin ça recommencera aussi vrai
que le raisin bonne du vin jamais le pt
le fraysse est à foix jean l'affront en
lui même serait terrible alors il faut
tout lui dire mais c'est mario et
effectuerait à ouïr au sein il ferait
certainement de son mieux et la
maladresse à ses miracles même dans
l'église il le ferait et moi il me
serait la maison je ne veux pas manger
le pas des autres
alors il n'y a plus qu'une solution
kouao bien à duran vérité tout dire à ta
soeur puis mon et c'est elle qui
porterait le fusion pp on s'en aller si
loin je ne pense pas qu'elle fera un
bouclier de son corps elle ne crierait
dans les rues maman est une sainte
marthe naturel
oui
c'est c'est gentil de penser à ta mère
non mais alors à
alors il y à dieu il n'a pas la notion
du temps encore un blasphème daté du ter
espérons que tu le paieras apa bon bah
moi je suis attendu
toute cette nuit je prierai pour vous
non mais ne désespérez pas quand dieu
s'en mêle il ne fait rien comme personne
tu as les papiers signés les deux oui
non c'est surtout s'il arrive pour que
je puisse dire ce que je fais ici vous
avez compris tiens tiens tu ne m'aimes
pas moi sherine mais nous sommes deux à
thé mais maintenant le bébé et moi tu le
sais que je ne me pardonne pas mais
c'est à toi de me pardonner c'est moi
qui t'ai dit ou orange à l'échelle
pierre je sais ce qui nous sauverait si
tu as une idée dit là le pp est vieux le
seigneur leur appellera bientôt à lui
on peut pas interdire mario l'impression
que ça se voit déjà le pp est encore
solide qui est le seigneur leylatoul
tonnes
on pourrait peut-être ne pas l'attendre
un coût constitue bien je pense que ce
n'est pas aux morts d'enterrer les
vivants le médecin a dit que le pp était
comme une de ses vieilles pendule dont
le ressort était usé et ben on avance à
un peu les aiguilles voilà tout
quand tu es fois qu'il foule mais non
tiens autrefois on ne se posait pas tant
de problème pour un oui pour un non ce
poignard des on s'étrangle est on se
foutait alors entre père et fils mari et
femme frères et soeurs sans y voir
malice
c'était maintenant c'est bien changé on
se garder rancune
alors si bon qu'il soit si indulgent
pour nous le pp nous haïr est pour
l'éternité
et ça même y penser m'est insupportable
tout comme à toi et moi plus qu'à toi
non c'était plutôt un rêve qu'une idée
mais même avec la bénédiction du pp
comment tu serais du prix bien tout le
monde sait que le pp tirs sur le fantôme
de temps bio ni les nuits de pleine lune
alors personne s'étonnerait si en
nettoyant son fusil la main du pp
tremble tellement un coup de feu
malheureux lui partait dans le ventre un
accident en quelque sorte
comment on s'en tient à des plus en plus
belles toi et ben qu'est-ce que vous
comptiez tous les deux alors on ne
comprenait rien pu y étiez donc j'étais
venu chercher des papiers que j'avais
laissé hier soir a signé à donna teresa
et advanced éléments laissant pas là non
non non ils sont a pas l'air ils sont
ainsi livrés les flancs de carriole j'ai
admiré hier il parlait plus belle joue
de toute la sicile ça donne c'est le mot
est un grand artiste
il met toute la joie de vivre dans ces
carriole je suis bien sûr que tous les
soleils qui l'a mis dans sa peinture lui
sera rendu au siège le seigneur tu
entendes en attendant j'aimerais bien
qu'il m'aide à retrouver ce bon à rien
de soucot par lot de soucot lui même va
falloir se lever de bonne heure
compagnie on raconte qu'il est parti
faire fortune aux amériques ballet des
revenus même les américaines on envoie
voulu il l'a extradé
même pas ils l'ont renvoyé à fond de
cale avec un grand coup de pied au cul
comme baiser d'adieu et prières d'aller
se faire voir ailleurs c'est pas de
refus c'est pas un temps à courir après
hors la loi non mais tu es sûr qu'il est
revenue oui on l'a vu rôder par ici et
justement je venais te demander si par
hasard tu l'aurais pas perçu alors on
offre une prime de 100 me liront celui
qui permettra de l'arrêter
je te souhaite bonne chance de gagner un
malheureusement vont gagner deux
carabines hier il n'a pas le droit de
toucher les primes ça c'est très injuste
c'est bien mon avis mais toi tu peut
s'emmêler à contre va se marier se fait
pas de mal 1
qu'en penses-tu l'instituteur non non
chacun son métier brigadier noble et
puis parlons de soukous était un copain
d'école
ross est quand même un lâche un
trouillard et la loi est la loi et zuko
s'est mis en dehors mais face aux
gallois quand vous étiez ensemble à
l'école il était toujours le premier de
sa classe
ah oui et ben déjà ça ça inspire pas
confiance
ce n'est pas un crime d'être le premier
à l'école même canton très chaud
propositions et tout le monde triche en
sicile
alors c'est vrai brigadier c'est
malheureux mais c'est vrai que pas plus
tard qu'hier j'ai rendu visite à marjah
frescaty et bien elle était en train de
coudre des petites poches spécialement
série n 1 qui se présente la semaine
prochaine au concours d'entrée au
collège de termine à roubaix c'est comme
ça qu'on fabrique de mauvais citoyens
si on n'a pas quand on est petit le
respect de l'école comment voulez-vous
plus tard avoir le respect de la loi
vient du bon sens dans ce que tu dis
leur manière assurément sûrement zuko
une fois sortis de l'école a commencé à
commettre quelques petits larcins
une bande de jeunes voyous de son espèce
on l'a arrêté juge et mis en prison sa
peine purgée il est parti aux amériques
et le voilà revenu et que fait-il
maintenant il a trouvé autre chose il en
bobine les jolies filles comme toi bien
vune fait passer sur le continent hélas
elles finissent sur le trottoir ou en
maison à la loi florence il touche une
grosse commission à chaque livraison
on dit même qu'il aurait plusieurs
filles qui travaillent pour lui à venise
il n'y a pas beaucoup de trottoirs grand
canal
méfie-toi pia si tu le rencontres des
comme toi il les avale sans les croquer
la connais même pas que dieu te garde ne
jamais me connaître pour qui la prends
tu l'antenne cet homme est le diable et
le diable a plus d'un tour dans son sac
ah les fameux saut merci pour la grimpe
à ma toute belle au revoir instituteur
au revoir il ya dix ans saisit quand
même 100 millions 100 mille lire mario
quoi puis les minutes passent plus j'ai
peur laon paniqué ce qu'il a dit pour te
faire peur aux non pas ni rien non non
je n'avais pas pensé au pt au pp
et si on découvrait que tu l'as tuée est
un jeu pourrez toujours dire que j'ai
appris la vérité au pp 1 et que sachant
ce que j'ai fait il est voulu me tuer et
que moi en essayant de défendre comme à
l'euro une partie non c'est sûr que
s'ils apprenaient le tuerais alors où
est le mal de se protéger quand on veut
vous tuer c'est de la légitime défense
réfléchit moi penser réfléchir j'en vois
plus un ça sert à quoi de réfléchi allez
bonne sieste
si tu peux
nokia non marine
laisse moi me reposer
et en tout cas et c'est comment est seul
oui oui oui
[Musique]
tu arrives une minute trop tard paulo il
y avait justement ici quelqu'un qui
cherchait à rencontrer le temps dès
qu'ils sortent pour te voir
chakim recherche mail en pagne est bien
trop con pour me trouver c'est un
honnête homme en tout cas si tu sais
encore ce que ça veut dire et je suis un
voyou ça aussi je le sais
non mais pourquoi es-tu revenue au pays
on voit du roi je suis revenu enfin le
mal du pays à bon dieu mort
sa revanche pas pu retourner en amérique
si je me présentais la paille mireille
gentiment de retourner d'où je viens
puis ces peluches toutes les fiches
avant nécessaire entre un italien
il faut dire qu'avec nous ils n'ont pas
été tellement gâtés mais pourquoi tu ne
m'as pas en france moi c'est plus
intéressant
le marché est bloqué par les corps avec
la fin je lis métier zuko le brigadier
m'a mis au courant
enfin tu seras prix et il ira en prison
c'est alors ici si tu fais pas tu es
vingt années de prison quand tu es jeune
quand est-ce que tu les frappes
[Musique]
à mario marivaux qu'est ce que tu
attends pour être enfin toi même un
mieux de rester à friot l'eau à tort
chez nous chez les gosses je peux
t'aider à sortir de la misère
ah mais c'est le paradis cette misère
ladesou cours qu'est ce que tu peux
m'offrir en échange il ya une belle
fille dans cette maison 1 1
on pourrait souvent avec elle c'est un
petit ami
non non c'est la cadette des chip
paulino elle n'est la petite amie de
personnes bravo tu me l'a présentée par
à 2 alors parlons il vaut mieux pour toi
je ne t'ai pas compris catchy paulino
est un dictionnaire matin des jeunes
c'est un financier parfois les photons
que j'appelle l'an passé tu touches la
misérable passé 10 ans de ma prime je
peux pas faire 100 fois plus moi tu t'es
heureux à les foules quand mes pieds
court plus vite que tes fesses
sont pas grossier ça mène nulle part si
l'argent ne dégoûte fait offrir autre
chose
bon maintenant tu fous le corps un mot
tu m'envoies plus ainsi je t'écoute tu
m'aides ici et je te mets sur un coup à
taormina avec ta jolie gueule sur
quelque 12 et u sera riche est peinard
toute ta vie au lieu de rester ici à
moisir en attendant une retraite qui te
permettra tout juste une plâtrée de
calamars bolognais a été gentil battant
du coup quand vite et loin ça va ça bah
oui allez ciao ciao
mais soit vieux que la campagne est
belle sous les arbres sont en fleurs ça
donne à faire de luxe et de faire à moi
je me serais bien passé de rentrer 1
bah oui parce qu'elles vivent ici 500000
a fait nul à luc st juste une maison
ciel se serait cru polio depuis dix
générations alors elle ne plaisante pas
rage il te plait vous savez dans le
cerveau on arrive plus vite au ciel en
partant d'une humble demeure que
d'appareils d'abord j'ai encore
affairistes emmanuelli que dirait long
que luigi si vous voyez arriver là haut
cette charogne de tomber que le seigneur
vous fasse lui survivre ne serait ce
qu'un jour de plus
avec votre permission je veillerai
moi-même à ce que votre fusil et sa
pleine charge de poudre avec je te
remercie mon garçon mais chaque fois la
bête ne m'échappe
que dieu vous entende le seigneur nous
attendait vous voyez dans quel embarras
pas que vous devez tri je suis venu pour
les papiers dans cet après midi j'ai
rencontré le contrôleur est bien trop
bizarre que depuis quarante ans vous
n'ayez déclaré aucun bénéfice de votre
terre de paix poli non mais au diable
contrôleur qua non à la fin août et
rocailleuse qui sent le soufre comme
tout le système à makhatchkala bon sens
- alors qu'ils foulent pas dans mes
prochains qu'il te plaît
le plan terre battue - cannois
maintenant heureux
l'offre intercoil ce qui sent le soufre
comme toute la sicile un sol aride s est
que le dit lui même il ne s'est pas la
terre de catane ici mon garçon c'est
peut-être pas la terre de catane mais
l'impôt frappe tout le monde le sait
selon les ressources et les revenus de
chacun ça foutait chaleur pense qu ils
s'arrangent toujours pour que les
pauvres soient encore plus pauvres gens
n'ont plus fait chacun pense que sa
propre 3 il a plu et j'ai fini les
pommes de terre
je donne un grand coup lécher les
babines maïs fait bien ma fille alors où
est ta soeur tu me l'avais pas donnée en
garde demande à l'instituteur jeter
c'est pourquoi les effets ensemble tout
à l'heure tu dois savoir où elle est oui
oui je sais où elle est oui elle est
parti se reposer demain theresa on
prépare les longs mois mon garçon je me
demande si tu as si ta fiancée sera
tellement contente si elle te voyais si
souvent dans notre maison
pourquoi vous me dites ça comme ça je te
dis pas ça comme ça je te dis ça
comme ça ces paroles ce médicament qui
est jolie fille en toi t on voir des
profils bien sont à deux mois d'un
donateur il assis dans sa cuisine et
l'orage des allumettes a connu des
cartouches
le jour où pierre voudra se marier fin
comme mario n'a pas cherché sa faisant
dans une basse-cour de village
oui ça vingaard et14 tout avoir d'un
taux atteint tout le du siamois un petit
verre je vois toi fou mais la paix
bien tout le temps tirer les cartes aux
amours de ta fille de l'airé droit
français devant le curé avant la cadette
ils sont déjà trop depuis trois ans j'en
tue son parti reposer au cimetière avant
le retour pour l'avoir oublié ce rabot
connaissait pas d'oublier peine 10 ans
ma fille à ton âge attendrait tout
plaisir toujours voulu par le bon dieu
se présenta ap les bons garçons qui te
fera une vie heureuse donc enfin nous on
a même trouvé un déjà il est venu voir
cet après midi pour me dire qu'ils
m'avaient rêver tout bien heureuse dans
le couvent des terrains tine tu me dire
que dans son rêve est expédiée à ces
votes d'appel qui a eu lui ont donc fait
beaulieu sont bien entendre chanter mais
mérite c'est dieu qui taylor voyais mon
enfant en le seigneur a bon dos nommant
jean à si donc aucun doute a dit qu'il
t'avait bihorel il ne l'a pas inventé
ouais
allez ça suffit non mais j'en veux
ces moines qui prêchait contre le vol et
quitter ce sans capuchon avec un art
qu'il avait dérobés il me prend pour
plus bête que je ne suis que ray bon tu
mêles couvert maintien seulement qui est
parti se coucher et nous avons mangé si
le diacre et de pizzas s'il est il voulu
remercier le pp tellement les pâtures il
a trouvé bale atp
si je n'invite pas mario je vais dîner
seul ça m'aurait fait très plaisir jenna
mais justement je vais partir maintenant
j'ai mes devoirs à corriger ce soir et
ma classe à préparer pour demain
rassure toi je ne voulais pas t'afficher
ce tête à tête c'était seulement pour
par la tienne
ni bébé et maman ne m'a dit qu'une bonne
nuit n'ont pas de chats que dans la
famille
dieu lui même n'est pas quand t'es
gentille de quoi at on peur et celui là
il a les pieds sur terre
allez toujours qui ce phénomène existe
cotriade au café le sergent de commandes
omar allure entre la galère 4,9 à toute
la sicile
il est aujourd'hui retraité de la marine
et tous une bonne petite pension
comment ce qu'un homme grenouille il ya
seul fattori il voudrait bien se marier
seulement voila voila quoi la cicatrice
une idée sur même de guerre à travers la
figure n'embellit pas son homme
mais à sa place j'aurais aussi peur
celui d'être cocu avec gina on ne risque
pas grand chose
c'est un bon garçon les filles les plus
laides et sont pas toujours les moins
chaudes jeu c'est dans ces mots pour ça
faut être deux machina et vertueuse les
seigneurs veille c'est vrai on va
jusqu'à présent a eu un point donné trop
de mal au génial j'ai de glace est
favori je m'en viens d'un pays où la
pression du scooter non non c'est un
silence et une heure
mirages des parents gerry bonsoir de
l'atterrisage bonsoir bonne c'est le
beau j'irai demain sera favori chercher
triano c'est un fiancé pitch
mais qu'est-ce qu'il a dû y la vie
j'irai chercher parce qu'on passe ou non
à l'otan
[Applaudissements]
des torpilles humaine voilà ce qu'on ait
fait des sous marins aménagé tout exprès
nous transporter à pied d'oeuvre
de là à cheval sur nos cochons des
cochons vous pourrez y dort jamais
j'avais jamais entendu dire qu'on avait
utilisé des cochons dans la marine
italienne massimo et cochons savant non
mais non c'était des tortillas faible
vitesse que nous avions baptisé comme ça
oui
une fois l'objectif atteint ont détaché
la partie explosive qu'on fixe et par
des crampons sous la quille du bateau et
on installait une mise à feu à
retardement
nous avons été les premiers pendant la
guerre a formé un groupe de volontaires
et à utiliser cette arme nouvelle
les hommes grenouilles qui nous happe
lettre nous ça nous faisait rigoler on
n'y voyait pas malice mais ce qui nous
appeler comme ça savez nous étions plus
gonfler encore que les paraboles en aval
et alors vous en avez tous les beaucoup
de coton mais on a fait du bon travail
dans ces mots gibraltar corfou senti
quarente à alexandrie autant de noms qui
parle à mon coeur des bâtiments de
commerce des croiseurs des sous-marins
ont coulé sono cours et déco pense
qu'ils sont jamais revenus
ils sont fait sauter avec leurs
torpilles plutôt que de rater leurs
cibles
ils dorment encore que dieu soit avec
ses héros quand la mère pour ses
cultures
oui vos fringues et au maillot papaye
autres contient 12 novembre au trianon
est en train de nous raconter ses
exploits
maintenant je ne veux pas vous déranger
je venais barratier non non non non pas
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est jour de
fête
c'est pas tous les jours qu'on souhaite
à tablât héros de la guerre
chez toi et nous protège le maillot tu
as écouté ça bonjour mario moi je les
écoute mais faut il quand on est si bien
bon ça m'étonnerait l'important c'est ce
que je pense
[Musique]
d'accès à l'eau
servi dans un petit verre de marchal est
celui éclaircira la vois mal et dépend
plus de lui
et bien moi aussi alors donné les coups
qu'ils avaient la peau claire à quoi ça
l'a fait pourquoi la paix les blocs avec
moi tout ça c'est une qualité plus
comment avez vous été blessés vous
voulez vraiment savoir
je ne peux rien vous refusez gina et ben
voilà le 18 décembre 1941
nous étions à un peu plus de 2000
duffar installé à l'extrémité du môle
d'alexandrie il était 9 heures du soir
la nuit était sans lune il y avait peu
de houle toutes les conditions de
l'attaqué et est idéal trois cochons se
met en route trois colons
n'étant pas du tout d'abord les cochons
non pas des ports des cochons oui je
pars à mon tour avec gatti notre
objectif de cuirassés un pétrolier
mouiller dans le port d'alexandrie au
moment où on cherchait un passage pour
franchir les barrages situés à l'entrée
du port voilà que s'ouvre pour laisser
passer des destroyers britannique
on entre avec le alexandrie en arrivant
près du cercle n'a biaggi plongea ai dit
cela je restais seul mais je réussi tout
de même à hisser l'explosif à le fixer
sous la quille du bateau avec des
crampons et a posé la mise à feu mais en
remontant à la surface
aveuglés par la vase que j'avais remuer
jeu fut fait prisonnier et à avec biaggi
qui avait réussi à grimper sur le coffre
d'amara nous avons refusé de livrer les
pubs notre mission mais on nous enferme
à tous les deux dans les flancs du
bateau quand celui ci fut secoué par
l'explosion
biaggi fut tué sur le coup à mes côtés
et moi même grièvement blessé
je fus conduit soigné à l'hôpital
d'alexandrie et la guerre était terminée
pour moi là-bas pour biaggi aussi
mais ce jour là nous avons porté un coup
très dur à l'escadre de l'hymne
britannique en méditerranée
comme vous le voyez c'est tout ça le
courageux paraît toujours cinq lots
héros et vous n'avez pas eu peur
seniors filles ados dans le camp du
bateau qui allait sauter mais ont si
peur qu'un condamné à mort qu'on mène à
l'exécution d'un intérêt c'est à dire
pour faire chaque fois est un peu
et pour faire pour faire ça fouette un
peu abîmée
mais vous avez raison dans ses mots
seulement parce que vous les barbares
nous étions jeunes que vous deviez être
go beau ça vous pouvez le dire avec le
caoutchouc noir de nos scaphandre le
casque les lunettes étanches marchant
péniblement à cause des palmes
vous avez l'air d'amour alors oui mais
ça c'est sûr tu es sur terre on avait un
aspect grotesque nous étions gauche et
malhabile mais dans l'eau les reflets
noir et luisant nos combinaisons nous et
ressembler à des phoques
c'est mignon setting beitenou zéro
défaut je voudrais vous demander quelque
chose est bien dit jean à je ne peux
rien vous refusez je voudrais pouvoir en
grenouille
ah oui bien sûr une petite échelle dans
un bocal et bien tout ce que vous
voudrez jean à un jour je vous ferai la
surprise à dante ou friot l'eau il n'y a
pas une fille qui est la moitié de votre
coeur mario ne m'a pas menti il m'a
beaucoup parlé de vous aimer vanter tous
vos mérites et il doit bien vous
connaître jusque il est l'ami de la
famille masina un grand coeur seniors
ian wheeler change procès d'alain coeur
un seul et même six fois plus de 300 un
pinceau jamais ça voyez vous c'est
toujours vrai pour les grands que moi je
parle bien dit moi aussi vous me
trouvais jolie
elles sont beaucoup dans ce rigolo que
je trouve moins joli et puis je ne crois
pas à la beauté du visage
c'est la beauté de l'âme qu'on a c'est
bien raisonné je ne suis pas moi-même
aussi beau que mastroianni non non vous
freinez pouces sages les vertueuses et
c'est le principal
comment je pense à toutes ces
dévergondée de la ville qui osent
regarder les hommes en face et erika
lien entre elles mais ma parole ça
m'arrive souvent avec des jus des jupes
qui leur arrive là juste amis qu'ils
qu'elle épouse bon tél
mais tous leurs maris seront coqueluche
je suis là j narbonne et poussins
qu'adriano aussi vrai que je suis sa
mère et que j'étais une bonne épouse
mais j'en suis certain de l'intérieur de
mon garçon ne jamais regretter des
torpilles alors alors là je ne suis pas
contre ah non je suis moi-même un joyeux
drille et perret et j'aime raconter de
bonnes histoires traîner avec votre
permission vais vous en dire une
c'est un impôt ni temps c'est un
napolitain qui a dix sept enfants
non non je n'ai pas terminé non gitans
napolitains qui a dix sept enfants alors
que ses amis lui dit quand même tu
exagères est ce que tu penses
quelquefois à la vie que tu fais à ta
femme avec ses 17 enfants napoli tendu
mais naturellement j'y pense mais c'est
sa faute aussi
elle est sourde tu dois enfin je vois
pas ce que ça change qu'elle soit sourde
et le napolitain explique tous les soirs
quand on va se coucher je lui demande
alors on dort ou quoi et aimerait devons
toujours quoi
ben oui
les enfants qui n'avaient jamais je n'ai
jamais je dois avouer que je les aime et
nous en aurons une ribambelle des
garçons des filles tout ça galopera
caillera j'en veux plus à la maison
qu'en dites vous dans ces mots oui enfin
fait cette raison d'abord un plus on
verra après faut que je me trouve
l'autocar de salles fattori part à
quatre heures et si je le manquer il ne
me resterait plus qu'à vous demander
l'hospitalité pour la nuit
cette maison est la vôtre seniors triano
merci d'un à teresa et merci pour tout
ah il ya bien longtemps jeunes avaient
mangé d'aussi femmes spaghetti à la
sarsat s'imagina qu'il faut remercier
seigneur briano à mes compliments gina
vous avez décidément toutes les qualités
d'une épouse parfaite je suis heureuse
que vous en soyez rendu compte par vous
même elle est et si douce
mais les leaders 6 9 me
et si souvient au revoir et que dieu
vous garde
voilà allez rien été a bien et bien et
puis nous allons raccompagné triano
tiens tiens en passant je vous ferai
part le petit champ sur lequel vous
pourrez faire construire une maison pour
y habiter quand on vous aura marier avec
gina ah ben je la construis un de mes
mains
au revoir dinars d'anselmo motorisés
fois l'embrasser
on porte bien on voit mario a en ce béni
le hasard qui nous a fait nous
rencontrer qui sait sans cela si je
serai ici aujourd'hui et si j'aurais eu
la chance de vous embrasser gina au
revoir
félécitations jean à eau je suis certain
que tu seras heureuse avec lui mais pau
est un bon garçon a tous remarqué toutes
ses médailles
moi jamais je n'avais vu à l'importante
en décoration on a l'impression qu'il a
gagné la guerre mais tous avaient c'est
un héros et jamais non plus un homme n'a
commis de tels exploits et puis tu
entendu ce qu'il a dit il ya des livres
qui parlent de lui oui il doit avoir une
bonne tension lente à se comprendre pour
les tp a une bonne idée
vous pourrez construire une jolie maison
dans le petit chien et nous serons tout
près les uns des autres
tu y as raison je suis certain que pépon
sera un excellent tamis pour moi et moi
j'en serais fier et moi aussi jean à toi
aussi tu seras fille être l'épousé d'un
homme aussi courageux et que toute la
sicile reconnaît comme son héros on vous
regarde
moi moi dès que j'ai vu il m'a plu il
est il est si bien si jeune si pleins
d'esprit
il est beaucoup plus avec toi mario ah
oui oui peut-être jean abattu c'est un
homme qui a tant souffert dans sa vie
qui a vu la mort de cyprès garde d'une
éternelle jeunesse de choeur oui oui il
ne fait pas son âge vous ne le trouvez
pas un peu laid les captures non moi je
n'ai pas remarqué jean âge j'étais sous
charles je ne voulais pas perdre un mot
de ce qu'il racontait oui oui oui
avec lui je suis sûr qu'ils n'aient et
j'en suis bien content pour toi je te
souhaite de tout mon coeur d'une arme
merci mario way si gentil à t'intéresser
à mon bonheur et puis sur toi toi bien
j'ai pas toujours été très bonne ni très
juste on n'y pense plus je n'ai pas
toujours un témoin non plus très aimable
mais je te retrouve aujourd'hui j'étais
souvent mal jugé mais tu es ma soeur et
j'espère
je me réjouis de ce qui t'arrive et puis
quels sont les seuls qui ne se sont
jamais un peu taquiné
c'est vraiment un yacht en réseau quel
dommage que tu sois fiancée bien aurait
fait une bonne épouse pour toi et nous
aurions été heureux tous les caps
ouais je suis sûr que tu as rosalia est
une brave fille qu'elle sera un peu
comme une soeur pour lui n'est ce pas
oui mais pourquoi si tu t'es pas jalouse
d'elle - enfants toi ma petite soeur un
jour tu verras tu rencontreras toi aussi
un garçon qui tu aimeras et que tu
aimeras et ce jour là ce sera encore un
jour de bonheur pour moi pour tuer
gentille et gina ont été bons sentiments
ne font grand plaisir à entendre
qu'en penses-tu mario ah oui
certainement djila oui qu'est-ce que
vous avez tous les deux
un secret jean a un secret que nous
allons te révéler qui va me faire
plaisir
oui un sacré quel secret au sujet de
rosalia de rosalia de rosalie ou heroes
a dit à n'existe pas et n'a jamais
existé c'est une invention mario rosalia
n'existe pas non bas et eybens les
lettres a eu des lettres de ma
belle-soeur renata et photos il faut
tout très latin la femme de son frère
qui fait le taxi à new york et bat
marion un sacré menteur dit non il ment
comme une épitaphe
et pourquoi tu t'es inventé une fiancée
bon ah bon parce que la mienne je ne
pouvais pas en parler qu'ils ne viennent
pas non c'est bien que j'aime
souvenez-vous le père dit
en vérité je m'en doutais bien un petit
peu on voyait un peu trop souvent mario
paraissait bon ce n'était pas une belle
invention a aussi très belle nous ne
quitterons pas sinon nous resterons
prennent toile et trigano
et oui je vais être nommé directeur à la
rentrée prochaine dont maggio homme
prend sa retraite et nous inviterons sa
grande maison près de l'école
je comprends pourquoi votre joie était
si grand que heureuse et tina et vous
aviez raison nous soyons heureux tous
les cas oui nous pourrions nous marier
le même jour oui à la seat anselmo par
exemple aux quatre mois
bah oui c'est la fête du pp et pourquoi
attendre si longtemps pour bien que mes
pompes à sa cour qui aurait pu le penser
si je proposais le mariage dans la
semaine 4 mois sa phase i owe you we 4
mois ça passe vite oui mais nous sommes
si un patient au massage ou comprend
djila tu as bon que moi aussi
quelquefois j'étais mal comprises tu
sais mal comprise ah oui vous m'avez mal
comprise vous êtes moquer de tout le
monde
à mon tour aujourd'hui ne manquer de
vous gina j'en étais sûr vous croyez que
je n'avais pas deviné votre manège faut
gagner pour une idiote
qu'est ce qu'ils trouvent il me prend il
me prouve que je ne voudrais jamais une
grenouille que je ne serai jamais la
femme d'une torpille humaine vous l'avez
vu ce trigano
vous l'avez bien regardez bien sûr
c'était assez bon pour moi il était même
trop pour gina et vous partager mon
bonheur le bonheur d'être capable d'un
monstre au peut-être qu'avec son
scaphandre
il aurait fait influencer présentable
mais on peut pas vivre toute sa vie mais
qu'un casque et des lunettes étanches je
comprends pourquoi toi l'instituteur tu
avais fait l'arctique à cet imbécile
pour u être certains qu'ils se jettent
sur la marchandise un homme cache vos
idées des cochons pendant toute la
guerre était tout désigné pour être
l'époux de gina car tout horrible qu'il
est vous n'étiez pas certain qu'ils me
trouve à son goût
qu'ils me trouvent pas encore plus laid
de lui je vous entends d'ici un article
du sage une épouse fidèle et pour cause
qui restera la maison à faire la cuisine
la lessive le ménage les enfants une
ribambelle de petites et à aller vous en
tous les cas je ne vois plus les
amoureux j'ai horreur de ça quand ils en
pensent de moi moi je crache dessus
toi tu
mehdi pour vous démasquer
mais tu vas faire beaucoup de peine à
cet homme il ne mérite pas mais vous
vous le méritez dénoncer nous fait que
la tels scandales sont monarchistes ou
cougar tiens je vais attendre
j'ai tout mon temps moi je ne dirai rien
je veux assister aux inventions mario ne
me déçoit pas toi je vais te voir
griller chaque jour à petit feu
mais non tu les poussera donc jamais
personne tuée décidé à rester vieille
fille il ya une ehpad et je suis prête à
épouser un salon est bien dit le vie je
la mets tout ficelé tour mario
[Musique]
c'est vraiment pour ce que vous faites
pp a mais je sais bien que c'est beau
jeune âge ccvo rousseau comme de l'or
oui enfin c'est ça la peinture puis j'ai
cependant la couleur qui compte c'est la
lumière celle avec égrenés à côté de
garibaldi la sceptique c'est santa
rosalia la patronne de palerme
on arrive à point pour un grand nom
d'abord c'est parce que là elle a les
joues creusées par les privations lance
un salut
est ce que du fait qu'elles évaluent
elle lui baissent les mains mais que
cette chute est c'était le bon dieu
garibaldi la pole à là c'était qu'un
seul bouton son costume vous mettait à
l'abri des balles condition que la balle
tape sur le bouton
c'est au tour de pierre devenir une
femme à force de poser pour toulon
madone si un jour il vous faut une
sorcière ou la femme du diable ne
m'oubliez pas moi je te croirais avec
toi ce que tu racontes pour moi la porte
bientôt fouler passe devant jari inutile
ça va mieux seul l'habitude son dos a
tué injuste gina tafer aussi fait sa
part de travail
je n'en voyais chercher des oranges
est-ce que je me plains maman non 28
ready pour x serait dire dans la vie on
aimerait le voir sourire de loin en loin
ça m'arrive quand je suis seul
pour ce que mon sourire et gracieuse une
vraie personne le trianon le trouve
céleste ton sourire mais tu l'as va
promener ça n'en fait jamais gagnent
plus cc 5e quand même
enfin encore rejoint je suis là jus pour
prêter d'argent qui leur plus on peut
commencer à désespérer de la mariée
jamais et oui on dit qu'il n'y a ni
laide marmite qu'il trouve son couvercle
va pour une fois qu'on avait trouvé un
couverte calé sur la marmite
j'ai mes raisons et l'effroi bonne au
map en fuite est plus difficile à aimer
tous les stores embolie je préfère être
bien détester comme aller me demande tu
as l'air bien des finances qui t'arrive
de ne pas être gay avec ce soleil du
monde c'est le mot lauriers roses sont
comme des marronniers la nature est
belle c'est pour moi que tu dis ça vous
avez votre nom la phase aujourd'hui de
l'intérêt zanon
non je viens vous apporter la demande de
renouvellement pour le bail de votre
terre de paix poli il faut la signature
dallas et en anglais alors j'ai demandé
au brigadier l'empa ni de passer tout à
l'heure pourquoi avoir quoi ma signature
alors je suis fier non qu'est ce qu'un
brave vieille carabine vient [ __ ]
là-dedans c'est la loi
oui enfin la loi pas jouer oui je vois
la maman les oranje mais kelly vous
souhaite un bon jour je lui ai promis
qu'on me rendre en visite aujourd'hui
j'ai rencontré d'enfants falot il ne
repassera par ici voir si moment
agréable pour ses pots konami qui m'a
dit qu'on peut on alors organisé une
procession a sauvé nato pour conjurer la
sécheresse et à pleurer saint joseph
nous envoyer là-bas depuis donc on lui
fait des prières à celui là beaulieu il
a eu le temps de la voir notre record
wen devant autant de gens l'auraient
enfermée dans la vieille chez christie's
des capucins jusqu'à ce qu'ils fassent
pour le voir qu'après les mêmes mais
savent pas ce qu'ils peuvent notamment
prié ne jamais désespérer la ville
serait morte sans l'espoir et le
désespoir n'est pas triste maman
bon ben dylan sans la lépi jeannesson a
battu marc ayrault les lie
mais moi je vais dans la cave c'est la
machette pour chercher un peu de
fraîcheur parce que le diable lui même
j'ai mal à l'aise dans cette fournaise
avant prenez votre santé facebook radeau
remis ça ce n'est pas dans ma chambre
est venu me réveiller un amant gmail sai
plus sceptiques à faire sécher et as tu
peux aller me reposer mais c'est trop
chaud gagner je serai dans la partie à
se fermer la porte
alors allez vite vite
et bien sûr tout le monde dort pas ce
que je devrais pas que ça foire et moi
tu crois je le voudrais bon alors fait
bien attention ici c'est la salle
commune la porte derrière toi tu donnes
dans la cuisine et dans les chambres le
ppa un sommeil de voir de l'intéressé ne
dort que d'un oeil mais sa chambre et de
l'autre côté de la maison elle ne peut
rien entendre quant à jean à je te
réponde son sommeil
1 et où est le nid de la ravissante là
elle va venir un jeune au courant des
intentions
elle n'est pas contre elle serait même
plus tôt pour juger ce n'était pas le
genre de fille à se laisser moisir dans
un bled miteux non non elle a décidé de
voir du pays
tu comprends ça toi de socoa
moi je n'y ai pas donné tort
bravo marion les secourir il amène la
mort comme promis n'oublie pas non plus
que tu m'as promis toi j'ai qu'une
parole
vrai aussi vrai que je suis athée et que
dieu existe
soixante mille et un 60 millions j'étais
sûr que ma proposition finirait par
l'intéressé tu es bien sûr de toi et si
elle n'avait pas marché
il suffisait que tu me la présentez je
l'aurais bien décider tu n'auras pas ce
mal j'ai fait le travail pour toi ouais
ça vaut bien 10 milliards de plus ce nom
et dont tu perds pas l'nord l'asti
pudeur
mais va pour les 10000 lire tu les a
bien mérité
voilà le compte y est
elle
ils n'ont mario si on faisait d'autre à
faire ensemble il ya quelques jeunes
filles dans ce village et du mal à
retenir parti prendre ah oui j'y
penserai craint l'imposition
d'instituteurs permet d'entrer dans les
familles par l'intermédiaire du petit
frère ou une petite soeur
oui bien sûr on verra ça plus tard un
terminions d'abord cette affaire là
ouais ouais d'accord va la chercher
j'ai pas de conseil à donner moi sous
comme est à ta place je profiterai de ce
que tout le monde dort ici pour lui
offrir une première leçon de choses ici
oui tout de suite oui on va pas attendre
demain à midi sur la place du village à
a demandé lui la voilà allez je vous
laisse ces affaires-là ne s'arrange qu'à
2 h 01
et puis
proche mignonne je vais pas te manger
bonjour s'ignorent ce coup appelle-moi
paulo jamais et c'est pas au lot par lot
tu vois c'est pas difficile hein pas au
lit no comment ça plaira
mais c'est que tes yeux s'en vont comme
la nuit était belle comme le jour
on a dû souvent de le dire seulement ma
mère ma part les garçons de free yolande
la polenta dans les yeux à les garçons
quand on prononce le mot ici le fusil du
pp lui sent dans les mains et au mardi
gras quand ils sont masqués
tu vois pas les yeux derrière le carto
non mais je veux les voir son masque
je veux vivre moi et viboud sait
s'amuser voir du monde
enfin pour voir du monde tu vas voir du
monde pour ma confiance et du beau monde
dans les peco cd reina flor ans ces
paroles n'ont pas pas ça fait d'élever
un braqueur de belles robes qui vous
attire aussi très petites voitures pour
les courses et une limousine pour la
messe oui oh oui oh oui je demanderai à
péter de ne pas être des anges sur le
capot oh mercy pauline où j'aurai un
grand appartement avec des taux mais
stick en abyme et oui oui c'est ça plus
les aura pu les en remercie non merci
c'est qu'il faudra t'il que je fasse
pour avoir tout ça comment vario tap a
expliqué non non il m'a simplement dit
qu'il faudrait que je couche avec des
hommes et que je souhaite très gentil
avec lui c'est ça c'est tout ah bah oui
c'est tout et c'est trop beau pour être
vrai moi j'ai cru qu'il avait menti
alors oui je veux commencer tout de
suite oui
ouais avec toi ben voyons très bien
décider s'il convient je ferai tout ce
que tu peux pas n'importe quoi plutôt
que de rester ici
oui alors tu parles moins fort surtout
tu dis rien à personne non seulement à
d'enfants fans c'est sa monture et
stéphane ont bien que je me confesse le
patronat dira qu elle a le secret de la
confession et tu crois qu'il va accepter
que tu sois une gourgandine mais oui les
plaisirs que je vais prendre
il me les a promis dans l'autre monde un
peu plus tôt un peu plus tard le 10
personnes tentant persuada soir à tampa
secours si c'est ce que tu veux aux
folles palin
je voudrais déjà être parti allez viens
vraiment son nom de l'argent ouah alors
alors c'est les américains qui était en
balance pas loin des amériques
ouais peut-être il y en a qui nous
emmènera avec lui
bon bah c'est pas impossible ça c'est
des choses qui arrivent à je te plaît
comme ça tous les hommes me plaisent et
ce sont ceux qui me permit aux qui me
plaît le plus alors comme toi tu ne me
donnes rien tu me plaît comme ça
je l'aï connue qui était doué mais alors
toi tu es parti pour faire une grande
carrière commence on est en haut
papa non si pépé se rebellent battus et
ne pourra plus venir avec moi
sans compter qu'il me prouve ici je sais
pas trop ce qu'il fera noir il tâte
hurel alors justement mais tu n'as rien
à craindre
hilda
et puis il faut tout nabias que je sache
c'est que ce avant d'engager tvn a oui
parlons marion des la bêta pendant de
dieu n'ont pas l'eau il ne faut faire
dassier n'est d'abord pas ton seigneur
quoi sim toi aller vite
demande pardon à tous
allez bien borloo
paulo pour la première fois je voudrais
dans le noir je suis très timide tu
trouves oui mais ça passera le premier
étranger qui rentre seul dans ma chambre
alors tu comprends va retrouver marie ou
dans le jardin joie mois dans 2 minutes
il fera nuit je te prendrai la main coli
à tout à l'heure
mon amour
c
alors oui sort s'il ya la sambre d'edina
médias du canada qui mois ap ap ap ap ap
paolo sorrentino de notre gina mon petit
poney pour nous voler c'est ma maman il
n'y a rien dans le golfe dans les faux
c'est bien le sida qu'il en avait un qui
moi to go bonjour tout le monde
enfin mademoiselle dieter oui mais j'ai
déjà dit bonjour tout le monde
les partis mineurs allez vous
m'expliquer un peu nuancer c'est elle
que je passais saluer on en souhaitait
les cochons salue les roses maintenant
non mais voilà je vais vous expliquer
sinon c'est vous qui payez les
magnifiques panneaux pour les voitures
toutefois avec mon chez moi et voilà mon
pinceau je te préviens qui lui arrive de
croquer la toile en effet a tenté mais
s'est expliqué pour la penn ar d'art à
tour 36 bonnes raisons s'introduire dans
un poulailler
alors vous avez la loge est un
malentendu si elle n'a pas de saint
valentin
longtemps j'ai eu ma chevet le progrès
un moment envoyé ici envoyé tant mieux
dit ça y est en lien avec un échec tant
mieux il avoue que c'est venir
est à payer pour des gens meurent chaque
maison ils auraient bien voulu nous
coller un petit bois taxes sur les bras
c'est sassignol en attendant laissez moi
partir quand on a eu l'honneur et
tripoli auquel je vénère s'ignorent tu
le fait d'être impossible
ça ne peut pas être atteint via me suis
dit qu'est ce que tu as ballon
maintenant mais tu as raison de ton
bionis n'a rien à voir là dedans c'est
elle qui l'a introduit site avait gelé
vu ma faute et c'est inquiétant minutes
été envoyée qu'est ce qui s'est passé je
veux qu'elle fasse un dessin histoire
c'est moi ta mère qui me paraissait
simple pour eux si tu me réponds pas
c'était tu là où je ne pourrais plus
jamais quand gardien pat mabille sera
toujours ça de gagné et maman
signorina enfin défendez vous dites la
vérité mais mario vous dira signe en été
à l'école ensemble fina voulez vous nous
dire ce que vous êtes venu faire dans
cette maison du coup je dois lui est dû
cet organe était envoyé trois mois mais
pour une fois il nous a rendu service
cette charogne
quand même tu peux tu as voulu
déshonorer cette maison va maintenant
elle est à toi tu vas y bouge et gît là
à l'instant même où j'en perds ta vie de
garçon - oui sinon voilà seulement j'ai
pas envie peut marier ce que tu m'as
demandé s'il voulait que tu bouges avec
ma petite-fille du lendemain a les mêmes
chercher le curé france
à la curée vous arrivez vient on a
besoin de boucs on a toujours besoin de
moi la paix soit dans cette maison
bouchard innogy et des pannes
que se passe-t-il on vient de recevoir
une demande en mariage on vous attendait
pour célébrer la cérémonie tout de suite
il n'y a pas une minute à perdre robben
l'honneur sicilien que le mariage sont
tous des quelques cafards a lancé m
enfin en tout cas je me réjouis de voir
que vous acceptez cette union en faisant
table rase de tous les vieux préjugés
comme un parent vous étiez au courant
bah vous oubliez teresa que je reçois la
confession je sais tout ce qui se passe
affriolants mais qu'est ce que vous
faites avec ce fusil là ça c'est pour un
bel et bien bien résultats sion du futur
si on avait on va en tout cas vous
pouvez ranger votre artillerie
je crois savoir que le fiancé est tout à
fait consentante mais witty le fiancé
vous disiez pas et vous disais pas en
confession c'était d'y retourner
il venir tous les jeunes n'a pas non
plus dormir on vient les surprenants
quand même c'est pas vrai je suis
innocent on ne tient pas pour innocent
le voleur qui dérobe pour apaiser sa fin
il faudra voir très fins culturelles
toit pour coucher tu étais d'accord à la
nuit tous les chats sont gris
mais maintenant ma petite fille et pas
assez bien pour tuer les pauvres je suis
pas dit ça sinon il ya longtemps que tu
m'as quitté frioulans mon fils et tu as
beaucoup voyagé à ce qu'on raconte
et tu reviens au pays pour te marier
raymond perdre mais c'est bien ça c'est
bien
il ya un proverbe qui dit choisis ta
femme et ton arme dans ton pays
mais fini changeant tueur ait quoi que
les fiancés circle chercheur et je ne
veux pas me marier je ne peux pas partir
c'est que je vais clash et des
cheminements épaisse main tu veux pas
que marié du nom tu sais pas je suis un
homme tient tueur de l'honneur du
polygone avant ou après monfils n'est
pas le courage du courage s'empêcher va
être effacée par le sacrement du nord
passé et recueille toi mon chéri gloire
à dieu au plus haut des cieux et sur la
terre paix aux âmes qui ont sa faveur
nos amis mais on nous allons nous allons
traiter talbot a coûté
écoutez râteau frenchy pillot ethnique
et de saint père et il s'écoule à ses
couleurs home à m bordeaux lorenzo
nastase jours pour accepter de prendre
pour épouse gina mariachis paulino ici
presse
oui le fiancé s'il vous plaît ça fait
rien ça fait rien je parle pour lui
alors il émit naître bon ça va répond me
souviens toi que tu parle pour moi que
moi alors dans ce cas ça change tout
pour le pp je pense à gina mariachis
prix n'aurait accepté de prendre pour
époux par lorenzo et la tâche de dioko
ici presque gina je te parle
oui j'oubliais
jamais les regarder pour la signature du
bail
nantes est une belle cérémonie tous les
deux jeunes mariés village de tombeur de
soupe au lait vie du village peuvent
dormir tranquille tu m'avais cacher ça
toi et moi aussi zoko alors comme ça tu
vas te faire arrêter bêtement le jour de
ses noces
parce que ça fait trois mois qui se
baladent au fond de ma poche pour mandat
d'arrêt lui il a fait quoi veulent et
assassiné peut-être pas aussi grave
proxénétisme
est ce que ça veut dire proxénétisme
ça veut dire que cette petite crapule
natation attention lampe année tu es en
train de parler du genre les seniors
cheapos lennon empêchait la faveur du
don en toi écrit non je tâte a dit
d'arrêter mon gendre et supporters ils
en ont maintenant
non mais laissez le parler mon fils mais
c'est de parler vous tirerez après tu
n'es ni rien de caché qu'il avait été
découvert il ya de ce fait que doit être
connu et mises à jour
havas résidente année mon père si vous
vous avez le secret de la confession
nous autres fonctionnaires de la police
nous connaissons aussi beaucoup de
secrets de la vie privée de nos
concitoyens dont le seul mot ce garçon
n'est pas digne d'être votre gendre il
se livre commerce qui est puni par la
loi et qui consiste à acheter de pauvre
fille de nos provinces pour les revendre
de riches américains
notre china sauf votre respect de nos
teresa ça m'étonnerait
ou alors une commande spéciale pourquoi
fait il ça
sa façon à lui de gagner sa vie toutes
ces filles ressemblent à gina ne doit
pas manger tous les jours à sa bouteille
et en bio nu qui l'envoyaient nous l'a
dit alors qu'en bulgarie bien sûr c'est
ton bio ni tête en paix ma personne et
je destinais pas qui est ce que vous
pensez maintenant que la police
marrakech mariage mais pourquoi alors
alors c'est l'amour et je ne vois pas
d'autre explication
et je m'en réjouis pour vous que si si
en tout cas vous n'aurez pas été marié
femme bien longtemps qui va falloir me
suivre zuko
je préfère ça pour la prime
ouais ouais à quel point ils m'offrent
une prime de 100 me lire à celui qui le
fera arrêter c'est moi qui vais toucher
la prime bébé cent mille lits bonsignori
n'a jamais raison rien fait une grande
carrière
bon je signalerai dans mon rapport que
c'est grâce à toi elle matin pour que
jean à face et haga son mari il en a au
moins pour deux ans ah oui oui que
veux-tu gina faut pas m'en vouloir mais
la loi est la loi c'est la loi tu l'as
déjà dit on fait de la loi c'est la loi
hier un brigadier de carabinieri c'est
peut-être que ce qui lui vaudra galons
de plus qui s'est jeté pour un gallon de
plus sur temps képi qui devait être à
une hausse de sa dette de plus dans la
tête
allez on devrait tout de même pas me
prendre pour un enfant de choeur
merci pas
nous avons fait une belle assise en
classe à nous la paix la map je me méfie
de tes bonnes actions
elles sont encore plus troubles que tes
péchés marie la mère de jésus
elle s'est bien trouvés enceinte avant
d'habiter avec josette elles étaient
seulement financé avec les tout comme
word et marion avec cette différence que
toi c'est quoi le saint-esprit qui est
en gros c'est alors vous faites pas
d'illusions tous les deux ce que je fais
c'est pas pour vous mais pour l'ange que
tu prends même sous ta jupe pécheresse
merci paris je vous attends tous les
deux au confessionnal vous devez encore
de drôles d'histoires à raconter
les bons soirs l'enseignement je me
sauve maintenant je vais prier pour mon
compte personnel cette fois et j'en ai
bien besoin
dieu soit avec vous abba pendant tiède
menus dont à ton bon dieu de veiller sur
mathieu soir pour médias pendant que
cette charente de temps bionique les
yeux du seigneur sont sur ce qu'il m
bonsoir on va mon fils mon père
et ben voilà une bonne chose de faite
bien et sans frais encore
charest avait déjà poster foutu
gouvernement d'où j'écris j'ai une bonne
affaire une bonne affaire en effet 14
les glam gaz et tu dois être heureuse
n'est ce pas et toi aussi marion mais tu
pourras aller voir sur coup à la prison
je t'accompagne reste deux ans ça passe
vite mais oui mais ça vous donnera lé 22
connaît il est pas mal tourné c'est du
coup et quand il sentira prison il sera
sûrement très heureux de voir bien sûr
après deux ans de privations il verra
venus dans une chèvre c'est s'annonce
chargée pour vous mais l'année d'heure à
ce site supérieur à la beauté petite
peste séquelles du s'il savait ce que ça
va être servi à ce duo il regrette de ne
pas avoir été condamné à mort
ah les années m'a fait dire de fleurs et
dans ta chambre toi et leur déchanté
quand je t'ai autoriserait je compris
alors quand ces deux là font semblant de
compatir elle me plaindre sachez qu'il
n'attendait pas au mariage pour se
marier à leur tour il me l'a avoué quand
ils ont su que j'allais épouse et la
grenouille passer ça vous avez déjà
essayé de me claude réauté attin est
bien faite m'enfermer l'asile et
affection c'est vraiment un changement
des nouvelles de sa rosalia qui n'a
jamais existé mais ils sont bien moqués
de nous c'est de là que la colère du
juste tombe sur vous dakar nous pourrons
être fiers d'annoncer que la trois
chambres est en prison aller en prison
n'a jamais d honorer ainsi si bien non
artisan ou fight mario aux warriors quoi
que je t'achète cette histoire de cette
histoire de rouge ayala rosavia bah oui
j'ai une foi ne regarde qu'elle que ça
mais alors injustement je voulais vous
en parler quand c'est le mot bon bah
c'est rosa lien ma fiancée
oui mais elle m'a trahi
voilà l ai même vu
elle ne voulait pas venir vivre ici dans
ce petit village du frioul o allah alors
elle s'est fâchée elle sait et elle a
fait sa demande pour devenir hôtesse de
l'air
je crois qu en cash de les tests de
l'air au milieu d'un grand le grand
amour dont tu nous parler mais quand
l'avez-vous à tripoli où ça y est hier
elle m'a écrit pour me le dire
juste avant de décoller vendre de coller
jeu provient de chez toi qui décolle
je n'ai rien inventé non non c'est moi
non pas parfait judas nous agitent cette
cliente n'avait jamais jeudi n'a pas
compris donc c'est le mot mais pas moi
moi sur le coup j'ai voulu dire de ce
coup de l'émotion j'ai voulu dire que
j'étais décidé à oublier
vous comprenez j'étais décidé à
l'oublier alors pour moi c'est comme si
elle n'avait jamais existé
voilà bon voilà une journée mouvementée
au moins j'aurai tort de faire ma sieste
eux parce que je commence à en avoir
bon alors personne a plus rien à dire
alors merci moi donc c'est bon ce n'est
pas encore fini non je j'ai quelque
chose à vous demander web et à vous
aussi de l'internât
voilà je voudrais vous demander la
permission d'épouser bien marion n'ont
pas dit rien à pula le rad plus heureuse
elle vous considérait déjà comme mon
fils guy lambert et toi qu'est ce que tu
en penses bien voudrais pas vous
déplaire tt
marion marion était tellement malheureux
quand il a reçu la lettre
ils étaient tous des appareils branchés
allier une fiancée qui s'envole et loti
tombe du ciel le même jour si vous êtes
d'accord moi je le vois rien à redire
mario est un bon garçon alors que ce
soit et si quelque fois qu'il change
d'avis toi brody drôle et ça peut
attendre une minute non mais qui dans un
mariage par jour je suis frustré alors
de ne répondre on en parlera demain avec
l'argent que je vais toucher pour la
révélation de ce côté c est bien vous
s'achèteront le petit cirque et danse
avec l'argent que tu toucheras pour le
reste on n'oublie pas que tu parles de
ton beau frère la guilde dans un mois la
moitié à ta seule salle ferrière j'ai 70
milliards d'économies je ne savais pas
qu'un instituteur gagner assez d'argent
pour faire de pareilles chez le promu il
ya moi non plus j'ai fait un petit
héritage
voilà
je voudrais demander la permission
d'embrasser ma fiancée l'a bien sûr
mario wii
oh
m
mais rivera envie c'est le mariage de
dooku et gina et préparer les papiers
pour le nôtre aller à tout à l'heure
moi je retourne vers ma chienne temps
parce que ce soir il me faudra veiller
il y aura avoue clair de lune je ne
voudrais pour rien au monde manqué mon
rendez vous avec cette sharon de tango
dit pas ce soir péter pour papa schultz
marché soirée bleue mais qu'on leur
foute la paix je suis heureuse non
mais toutes ces émotions épuisé c'est
vraiment le single she paulino ya du
nouveau
ces caisses qui encore vous allez le
savoir et non pas parce que nous on
aurait dit il n'a pas pu oublier ne se
serait pas laissé manu comme ça sans
rien dire mais il n'a pas oublié il a
déjà pensé à le dire
ce manque pp avait le fusil sous le bras
il sait très bien ce que l'honneur lui
aurait commandé en vain mais les
chipeaux lino ne badine pas avec
l'honneur la caisse pourquoi vient
troubler machin qu'est ce qui se passe
le temps de viognier nombreux s'agit
bien du temps bionique je viens vous
parler de zouk au goût à montjean votre
jean il est pas plus votre gendre
comment un cousin du pape
quelques-uns du pain là
et je t'en prie arrête de parler pas
réduit on comprend rien du tout alors
les gens qu'on comprend pas tellement
bien que je t'explique clairement non
alors écoutez moi bien zobo une fois
bouclée dans sa cellule le voilà qui
commence à recanati et à me raconter que
son mariage avec gina était une
plaisanterie
ouais une pouliot n'a vu qu'il était
déjà marié en amérique
je ne veux pas le croire il insiste je
téléphone au commissariat central de
palerme ou via le service de
renseignement et là on me confirme que
c'est la vérité vraie
ce qu il a été marié trois fois et qu'il
est poursuivi par ces dames pour
escroquerie vue qui les a quittés en
emportant leurs petites économies et ça
le jour où elles touchaient leurs
pensions de veuves de guerre montrant
oui je vais jamais l'abattre comminges
d'azun fumée la bonne sans mots je le
devoir de veiller à la sécurité des
prisonniers de youtube veille sur tout
bientôt on pourra plus aller pisser
chanté par derrière
elle a peu trop de ce qui le regarde pas
président il faut laisser faire la
justice
il sera jugé comme il le mérite je ne
veux pas laisser mon honneur à la merci
de la justice
et même si je dois que descendre avant
de gérer vu crever le payasage
funérailles âge de mariage quelles
nouveautés célébrer là bas il sans
valeur de l'intérêt sans tamada il
appelle à magog
si tu prends tu lui intéresse après tout
ce qu'elle a vu un blasphème pas gibier
dans fait je dîne à une amap leur part
le mariage ne compte pas beaucoup
avaient déjà une bonne dans son lit
tuerait boucher ou ma fille non elle a
tort de pleurer jean à pleurer sur son
malheur c'est en arroser d'autres pour
qu'ils poussent plus vite
toujours le mot pour rire toi
c'était terrible il n'y a qu'une chose
terrible en ce monde dont seulement
c'est d'avoir mal au dos bonne nuit
il est gentil oui mais alors plus con
que lui en veulent j'ai voulu la beauté
sa mort du web pc en fortis a mordu et a
mordu la part du mollet choix seul avec
elle je lui parle et non mais ne vous
fiez tu perds mais j'en ai vu d'autres
alors elle soulève toi seul avec elle et
je vais les choix sociaux que tu vois je
suis je suis vieux bon alors tu t'en vas
mouche tijd
aulas
ouais arrive toi à l'été bien oui ou non
quelle famille en a une tu veux pas
partir tu veux pas rentrer je te
préviens je compte jusqu'à 3 1
jia 3 tu n'es pas là moi je viens je te
fout une fessée cul nu devant la fenêtre
ouverte
je commence alors jusqu'à 3 1 2 j'irai
pas plus 24 ans de produits je te
préviens quand tu fais c'est que tu es
clashs ça t'arrange pas toujours en
fuite
quoi qu'est ce que tu racontes d'autant
plus un support était pâle elle ne
parlait que du tout cesser tout dans ton
visage a du caractère c'est tout se fait
en volume envisagé comme moi il ya un
fil un caractère moi je te dis ça parce
que parce que là ce qu'on aime ou l'ordi
toujours les choses en face ouais ouais
bah oui mais moi moi moi je t'aime c'est
pas moi vous aimez c'est bien c'est pas
tout le monde aime quand vous parler
d'elle c'est comme du sucre
et puis surtout sur le sujet si tu te
trompes et j'ai pensé à ça si je
t'aimais plus de pia justement votre
pitié me fait honte ordif européen
qu'est ce que c'est ça qu'est ce tu
parles de pitié moi puisque je m'inspire
c'est pas mal de passeport aux malades
j'aime bien avec mes yeux mais toi je
t'aime avec mon coeur j'ai hyper rien
mais peut-être que ce que tu gagnes tu
appuies pour les poulets cou nu poule
lève la tête lève la tête pour que quand
je te dis quand tu tiens les yeux
baissés c'était bon dieu tout est si
fermé où lui a été plus la relève la
tête
voilà comme ça oui ça va et puis vient
ici bien ici je vais te faire voir
quelque chose mais toi la bouche pour
qu'un regarde regarde sur le tableau en
bas à gauche entre saint françois et
saint clair la bonne femme qui est là
entre 560 et là mais non pas là c'est
pour une bonne forme saas et le pape là
celle-là il sait là tu vas pas nous
l'affreuse l'affreuse créatures qui
balance un coup de pied à la vierge
agenouillé je sais quoi tu sais c'est la
femme de l'ancien bedeau votre ennemi
qu'elle était en 14 depuis le temps que
vous la mettez toujours à la même place
rapp en carriole vous ne pardonnez pas
me dubois ce n'est pas ça du tout j'ai
pas la femme du bedeau
c'est j'ai la mienne
ah oui c'est ta grand mère c'est ta
grand mère d'angelina celle qu'a eu le
premier prix de beauté
le prix de monter ça sûrement pas le
prix de la meilleure pizza est pas la
même chose
eh ben c'est elle est à grand mère puis
son portrait craché
oui encore un jeu les plus tôt un peu
avantagé
c'est un g20 voilà non mais tu l'as pas
connu éléments temps mais tentons pas
pas aux mots paumés mais je vais
l'appeler elle a dû souffrir pourquoi
parce qu'elle était laide pas du tout
pas du tout
ah non elle disait que disait que le bon
dieu l'avait fait qu'au mérite et qui
avait rien à dire c'était son droit de
faire des femmes belles et des femmes
laides
il avait sûrement ses raisons et en tout
cas qu'il en avait la permission et je
te jure que non
avec elle il avait jugé que la
permission pourquoi qui annule ensemble
porte
j'aurais voulu que le partage plus
équitable mais à tout prix une fois
personne ne le croit
dis moi qu'est-ce que tu préfèrerais que
pia te ressemble
vous ressemblez à bien ses versants une
torsion oui j'en étais sûr
oui c'est pas très beau sujet m'enfin je
vois ce que tu veux dire
et vous l'avez poussée de l'homme comme
vous deviez être en ce temps là bas je
comprends que tu es que j'étais j'étais
peut-être le le plus bel homme de tout
qui tarit enfin oui enfin un des plus
beaux
ma vie est rudement aimé les pizzas oui
j'ai détesté pas mais surtout je me suis
mariée avec le curé devant moi mais
derrière il y avait le papa d'angelina
elle son fusil sous le mois et le doigt
sur la gâchette va décidément c'est une
tradition dans la famille avec mémé
saviez déjà
ah oui si j'avais déjà couché avec l
homme contre oui pour une fois une fois
qu'une petite fois de rien du tout à
quoi me regarde pas comme ça alors au
village avaient braqué le monde joueurs
alors un jour que joe j'avais vu un
petit coup de trop et le vin coulaines
par les oreilles et et
j'ai pris mon vol et avec la reine de
saba
qu'est-ce que ça sens pouvoir tout ça
quoi pour moi aujourd'hui ce que ça
change et ben reviens ici je vais te
gâche que ça change
je suis toi la figure toi que
tiens toi bien figure toi que sans le
faire exprès petit à petit sans mon
apercevoir j'ai commencé à les mettre en
mer - votre temps je me méfiais parlera
aussi l'embellie s'est pas bien sûr et
enfin pour les autres a été toujours
pareil mais pour moi non moi je la
trouvais tous les jours lui joue un peu
plus belle j'aimerais bien ça me tient
quand elle est morte j'ai voulu me tuer
je l'aimais à en crever pourquoi tous à
bp demain matin je rentrerai aux
ursulines de donner un dieu
ça lui apprendra
écoute moi j'écoute moins d'impôts
trigano est un bon gars chaud c'est ici
trois mois c'est un bon garçon chessbaby
et pousse le épouse les tiens toi dans
trois mois
by tu tues accueillera les chiens perdus
et tu mettras des soucoupes de lait
devant ta porte pour les jeux abandonnés
mais cynthia du chagrin c'est peut-être
toits qu'il dormira port ces jours là
avec les rois de la ch'ti et poussera
des gens vont trouver une voie steve
abana une bonne chose ça lui dans sa
tombe bien il ya justement un nuage
situé dans le jardin
c'est une bonne chose parce que ce jour
là il va arriver
moi je le sens qui est pourquoi j'ai
besoin d'hommes qui fait envie voyez
vous aurez pas parce que d'abord parce
que je veux bien car ensuite c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai il fait pas
l'horreur c'est toi qui te fait une
faveur tu me suis parce que tu penses
que tu es plus elle à l'intérieur qu'à
l'extérieur tu te laisses aller ils te
rendra heureuse j'en suis sûr il te
rendra heureuse comme gérant du heureuse
ta grand mère parce que meurent en
dehors il a vu il a vu le pire ils en
demandent mais il lui reste plus pour
découvrir les mais il est fou tu te
trouvais belle avant peut au nom des
places elle
portrait
l'homme
c'est des trucs comme ça
à mon âge marié de 50 alors bon
justement parlez vous avec jean atteint
j'avais promis de lui faire la surprise
alors faire un peu plus longtemps qu on
va essayer champéry là ils
interviendront regarde vous êtes beau
c'est original
bonsoir d'un teresa comment vous
portez-vous depuis hier ça pour aller
mieux
china china vient voir il ya une
surprise pour toi
j'avais bien fait
enfin monsieur gilchrist crise paraît h
et l'émotion chasseurs f-16 mais ça je
la comprends n'avait dans ses grands
jours
sinon c'est bienvenue où elle m'a dit si
enfin comme ça tout de suite
oui si vous permettez seigneur tu
paulino je t'aime il demande à rêver
c'est maman qui va être contente elle
meurt d'envié de vous connaître autant
que le mariage se fasse le plus tôt
possible
oui le plus tôt possible mais pas rigolo
à salvatori je vais chercher mes
affaires
aux affaires j'avais pas remarqué qu'il
avait des grands prime c'est vous dire
que vous êtes venu comme ça par
l'autocar non seigneur tu paulino un mes
amis m'a prêté sa vieille voiture pour
le voyage battus à faire mais je sais
que j'ai eu beaucoup de mal pour enfilé
ma combinaison depuis tant d'années mon
tour de taille a pris quelques
centimètres enfin pour mieux vous
puissiez l'enlever déjà prêt elle était
impatiente elle nous attendait coli
la mi match les filles se font pas peur
je sais pas qu'est ce que tu reproches
qui arrive à un pouvoir qui passe avant
ta soeur toucher ça peut être un peu
comme maintenant un tout petit peu oui
des combats alors s'attendre à bon voilà
allez une chance pour ce soir c'est
moche et pas la peine ce soir chez son
dernier choix
bonsoir d'un theresa may soir n'en
oublie pas ses mots bonne nuit ma fille
la suite demain
le
c'était fait le guet mais je ne veux pas
tu me quittes ce soir ne t'inquiète pas
je vais demander à travailler de me
remplacer je vais passer la fausse barbe
vieux chapeau
je ne quitterai plus mon amour
[Applaudissements]
et encore
la pièce que nous avons eu le plaisir de
jouer devant vous et de jean-jacques
brit air et maurice lasserre
la mise en scène et de michel roux
le décor et de simone unis
avec lahoud elle bosse
bouleversée
jean barney
un labo
mireille d'une croix
le michel beretti
jacques alric
ginette leclerc
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]